aunt ro Santana welcome to the show I
think one thing that I was talking to
you about backstages this is what
started as primarily an NFL draft
podcast and so if you guys can go back
in time one of my favorite questions to
ask is a natural you go first what was
your draft moment like you guys were
both very early picks what was that
moment like for you getting that call oh
it was a great moment for me I got asked
to come out to New York I'm not really a
big fan of the spotlight anything like
that so I was like no you know I think
I'm gonna turn down the offer and then
my dad was like wrong with you boy like
this is a once in a lifetime opportunity
now I remember Gil Brandt was giving me
a call and he was trying to force me to
come and I am going up to New York for
the drop that man let me tell you
something I'm glad that I actually you
know embraced that moment and took it
for a head-on man because it was it was
a once-in-a-lifetime experience
mine was a lot different you know I knew
I was going first round just didn't know
where some folks were saying from what I
did that year I should have been the
first receiver taken but I'm five foot
ten so they was like hey here in there
it would never be a guy that small go
first receiver so we knew it was gonna
be somewhere mid first round or later
and surprisingly I went sixteen pick to
the or to the Jets the week prior that
week leading up to the draft I got all
my calls from Washington DC and I'm one
of those guys like I'm not from Missouri
but you have to show me I'm not fitting
to sit here and Bank on going to
Washington but that's what everybody
wanted had me protected going and come
drafted a Schottenheimer good thing that
I was in my home with no not a lot of
family around just my mom my dad and my
brothers I wanted to keep it neutral I
didn't want all the party and all the
festivities until I actually got drafted
I was in the house and Schottenheimer
wanted to taught a receiver so he took a
rock Gardner and he was with Washington
he was a quarterback I mean I'm he was
the head coach at that time and the next
pick the Jets moved up and got me at the
16 pick so do you remember how his NFL
career went rock god I remember vividly
because always remember I came back to
Washington he was supposed to be still
there you know someone I got to get you
know so I played four years in New York
and 2004 is my last year there I get
traded to
in 2005 and talking to coach Gibbs on
his second stint he's like it's gonna be
you at the Z receiver and rock garden
would be IX receiver well rock garden
wanted out he wasn't happy with what he
had done you know up to that point and
probably I was like the last time I
heard him well I grew up in New York as
a Jets fan and you were one of the rare
first rounders that we were ecstatic
about but obviously a lot of your
playing days was we're at Washington
yeah were you excited to go there
because of all the pre-draft interest
there you obviously had some former
college teammates there what was that
transition like we're going to New York
going to Washington from York going to
Washington from New York I wanted out of
New York period okay not that no offense
to now there's a bad time my experience
is there just it just didn't add up to
what I expected to interfere to be like
out the gate I got hurt and the media
got on me for just being injured you
know I couldn't do nothing about it you
tell you Neela what can you do you know
and I bounced back from there in had
three stellar years I was a pro Boston
at two years out of four years I was
there one that's a punt returner and
once that's a receiver so you would
think that hey this guy has me live up
to the to the height and then my fourth
year when they knew I was supposed to
get paid the team itself tried to
blackballed me they didn't want to give
me the ball because they didn't want to
have to pay the big bucks for me and so
that year still put that behind me we
went to the playoffs
I played big I led the team in yards
touchdowns had two touchdowns in the
playoffs and I find myself in Washington
like how could you possibly have a guy
of my caliber go out your door after the
performances I put on the last three
years so it was to me like a Sodom you
know it was a sign of relief because now
I get a chance to start over and
Washington was something that I thought
that was supposed to happen way before I
got in New York and actually you were
the eighth pick in the draft
so going to Arizona how much of an
adjustment was that for you being a kid
that you're from Miami you go to you and
now you're in Arizona in the [ __ ]
desert
what tough is that it was a huge
adjustment like you say I'm born and
raised in Miami I've been I went to
college at University of my I was in my
in my whole life and all of a sudden 22
years old BAM know you're in Arizona you
know you're four and a half hour flight
away from Miami you know it was tough it
was tough because before the draft there
was
two places I said I never wanted to go
one was Green Bay and the other was
Arizona and the reason why I didn't want
to go to Arizona it's simply because of
the bad taste that was left in my mouth
from you know the 2002 national
championship where obviously everyone
knows about the flag and Ohio State it
just left a very bad taste in my mouth
and I didn't want to go there and sure
enough you know I get on the phone and
hello you know it's very green yeah it's
Danny Green me you know you have to put
on the front you you're always ecstatic
because it's a once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity but I did not want to go
that far away from home and more
important I did not want to go to
Arizona Cardinals who had a losing
record for I don't know how long what
was it like getting there because you're
one of the few guys that shut Larry
Fitzgerald down in college how much
trash talk was there back and forth
between you two when she got to the
Cardinals it never ended never not only
did I sit him down but I busted his nose
no mistaken you know he never let me
live those moments down but you know
that he became one of my one of my
better friends and one of the hardest
workers I've ever seen you know until
this day on a gridiron you know he's a
guy that you know how he how he's been
over his career it doesn't surprise me
because he's a god honestly he plays the
way he practiced each and every single
day he's the only guy I've ever seen
catch a ball and run a hundred yards no
matter if it's a slant a hit or a
failure out he's running a hundred yards
every single every single time the ball
touches his hand in practice an intro
one thing I love about your career it's
almost like you had two different
careers you came in as a superstar
corner and you finished as obviously an
all-pro safety but a Super Bowl winning
safety what was that transition like
where you've been a shutdown corner from
college to the NFL you played nickel
then you go to safety were you happy
about it or what kind of upset at first
you know boy that's not a everything no
and when I went to Arizona a universal
mom we played press man I never
backpedal one down at Universal Miami
and when I get to Arizona tell me okay
we want you to play nine yards off but I
have to play every route he's a receiver
he knows that if he runs a slant and I
buy him the slant and he runs a slant
and go that's touchdown he's gone
yeah it's gone so as a corner I was a
guy it was all mental for me I never
wanted to give up any route I don't care
if it was two yards or 15 yards I just
carried that much weight on myself so I
can never really play as aggressive as I
wanted to because I was always scared a
double move so I never really got beat
for touchdowns but I gave up the seven
yards the nine yards and it didn't it
didn't work for me so we get a new coach
coach Whisenhunt my third year in and he
obviously had a different mindset you
know he was like I'm gonna bring in
Rahul from Philly then they started Eric
green so I at that point in time became
the nickel coin I remember that I was a
nickel corner
I didn't power you know I just put my
hair down and kept working that's what
we know for Miami you know tough times
don't last tough people always do yeah
and at the end of the year well during
that year that's when I had one of the
best games in my career against
Cincinnati playing against Chad Johnson
Chad Johnson I had a mutual friend and
he told my friend ma'am I was looking
forward to burning your boy but man I'm
not gonna get a chance because he's not
starting and when he did that
honestly it struck a nerve with me so
bad that I watched film until honestly
like my eyes was just literally closed
at night and I studied film and I study
his routes and I studied the quarterback
and I said Carson Palmer is very
aggressive even when he's even when the
receivers are covered he's gonna throw
the ball so I knew third and short they
were gonna run out of hooch masada
I knew third and eight to ten they were
gonna run their double slants trying to
get Chad Johnson so I was picking those
off left and right and I'm a returner
you know this what we do we young we're
always offensive players so when I get
the ball in my hands it's going back the
other way and from that point on the
entity at the end of the year the coach
said man listen we got to have you on
the field where you want to play a
corner safety I said I don't care just
put me around the ball and that's how
that sort of transition went for myself
I never knew that Stern you mentioned
being returners you have four punt
return for a touchdown year last year in
Miami yeah for which I mean I'll brag
for you because I don't know credit for
that that's a hell of a lot of power
turn touchdowns yes you did you feel
like you were better at threat as a punt
returner or as a receiver or just I mean
you were all purpose right as no
Americans
surprisingly great question surprisingly
I never know I was a punt returner I
mean I spent my whole childhood years of
playing Little League in highschool ball
as a kick returner and I remember the
day that returning was presented to me
by coach Davis two of our guys went down
we got the week we you know back-to-back
weeks and he came up to me jokingly the
first time and he was like hey I need
you a punt return and I was like ain't
gonna happen coach I just saw how guys
had to sit there and we own the ball and
if someone's not blocking I mean to me I
just thought it was like one of those
things like if you want to set somebody
up that's the best time to set them up
so I'm like coach's impossible I never
did it one and then two I'm not trying
to take those licks that's one of the
reason why number guy in the backfield
because folks wanted me to be running
backs growing up but I didn't want to
take those hits and the second time my
guy go down the next week he say I need
your head part return Center and I was
like angle happen coach he said no this
isn't
I'm not action so I'm like oh serious
the next week I go back there we play
East Carolina now remembering he's
Carolina beat us that game but I had one
of the one of the nicest punt returns
ever and that was that started my career
and what we understood by just watching
me as a perimeter and what I began to
understand a little bit myself is when I
got the ball in my hand and anything had
happened you know it made me believe
that I just needed the ball now you know
so throughout my career in Miami I look
back on it a lot now that I'm retired
and I'm just I've been thinking now cuz
I tell folks all the time when I played
in the league I barely thought about
college I was so in tuned I'm doing what
I had to do now and didn't want to fail
that what I was doing now I didn't look
back so now that I look back at that
stuff I'm like man you just had to get
the ball in my hand regardless of what
way he was doing it I was gonna make
something happen is that a mindset you
develop from being a walk-on I don't
understand how you were a walk-on anyway
like it for three kind of speeds because
of size it's just an amazing store it's
easy to be you know the guy that I was
because you know I go to high school
where they did it the right way you know
care City singing high down in Miami
I'm pretty sure I'm not everybody's
familiar with it but we did it the right
way there you know our coaches didn't
let guys go both ways
we ran the Wing T offense where you had
two three backs in the backfield option
quarterback and we ran the ball half of
the time
my senior coach said hey it's time to
throw the ball we got out we gotta go we
know we we have a chance to go to state
let's open up this you know his offense
that's when I made my noise so getting
into Miami was I was a walk-on I could
have went anywhere else to be a football
player but I took the opportunity to get
into Miami and beyond just you know
being a walk one my mentality was to go
out there and earn minds and so I've
always was gonna go out there and give
them you know more than what they
thought they had out of me because
that's just how I was brought up for
both of you guys did you ever think
about going anywhere other than Miami I
mean just being from there and
especially the time periods that you
were there you know during high jump all
over this question because people don't
know that it's funny from Miami and just
like trill we both from Miami you grew
up loving everybody you kind of like
Florida State you like Florida and you I
never saw myself going to Miami because
I was a fan of Miami but I want to leave
home and I was a chief in high school
and we had we had the same term yeah so
I'm like it's only right for me to go to
Florida State because we can't really
talk in this yeah but by my junior year
Spurrier was throwing the ball
ridiculously at Florida yeah and
everybody that touched the ball there
was getting Italian yeah and so that's
what I was intrigued with like eight I
have to be a gator because all the
receivers from jock wears green I hear
the guy so I grew up watching their are
superstars I want to go there and do
that so by my senior year I wanted to be
a Florida Gator because of this the
receivers alone I was so you know and
love what they receive was mostly jock
wears green because I thought he was the
type of receiver of my same stature punt
returner you know he's a return guy he's
a guy that you know catch the look you
know hitches and take him to the house I
want to be him and it's crazy high
running it happened I was him in another
form in Miami
how about feet I mean you remind me all
the way right no no no no I was actually
Florida I was Florida I was I was a
Florida guy I like Miami
but I didn't follow Miami as closely as
I may be as a sure you know being that
was my backyard but I was in Santana
Moss fan you know so I will always watch
him and and my favorite thing with
Santana's like when he got a ball it was
it was almost like poetry in motion
the Run style the for me it was almost
like is it for real like it's real
running because everything was just so
smooth so I was I was a huge fan of that
but I was I like I like Spurrier you
know I was blown away with the visit to
Florida but I went to one you were in
practice unofficial visit I went to one
you were in practice and I saw the way
those boys got down and I said nah ma
this is where I belong because it was so
competitive and like it was little like
they were trying to kill each other
that's really important it was it was
like they were honestly trying to kill
each other almost a fight every day way
that but when that whistle blew
I never saw a Brotherhood like I saw
there and it just made me feel so at
home I was like man this is this is
where I belong and from that moment on
there was no questions I was you I'm all
the way you guys didn't overlap right
you were no you got drafted and you came
in right after that so how did you how
did you become friends then you just
know the guys I mean like he just spoke
about the Brotherhood
I heard the trip you know growing up in
the area and you see the all the high
school games so you know who was who and
then when they had they recruits you you
know especially when you leave you come
back to the games and you're watching
the game so you see the talent and
anyone my number so it's like I'm
watching them and sit right watch the
guy who got what I had on and for him to
be a DB it stood out you know damn this
guy here Magus you know causing havoc
but it was like crazy like he said he
was defending my life and here's and he
didn't even know that I didn't even know
he was a fan of my growing up but this
is how things is in Miami one of the
things that allowed us to be who we were
you know as players on and off the field
was the guys that came back when I saw
the Michael Irvin's you know the Ray
Lewis's the Warren saps the guys that
walked in those doors Lamar Thomas and
the March Thomas came to me I remember
this thing like it was yesterday
we get me to play Florida State at Doak
Campbell
that Mark Thomas came and spoke to us in
the meeting room the week of the game
and he said if I don't see you guys
dancing on the field when they start
their chant I'm gonna tell coach to get
you out on the field you all you have to
feel like that's your song it was my
song I grew up in high school that was
my that was our chant but he said you
gotta let these guys know you got a
psyche their psyche out to let these
guys know that you're for real you're
here to do what you got to do and I
promise you you will intimidate these
guys because they want that to be a part
of their game they want to come out
there with that Indian and do all that
stuff and they want you to be
intimidated by but you have to you have
to relish in that moment and I remember
being in Doak Campbell and we're down
the touchdown and I got like 180 yards
and two touchdowns and I'm saying he was
in line this is you know this is the
best game I've played up to this point
against Florida State and I was loving
every moment of where he lost that game
but I remember leaving that game and CJ
talking to me and saying man you know
what it was nice coaching you cuz he
thought I was done cuz he should tell us
when you play against the Florida State
a competitor like Florida State and you
play at that level all the scouts saw
that everybody in the world hang about
that it's time of you to go and I
remember just saying to myself like yeah
whatever and didn't have much to say
about it but all that stuff came back to
me because out that was Lamar Thomas in
my head the whole entire game motivated
me and encouraged me to go out there and
play at a level that I didn't even know
I had tapped into yet and that's what
gave us the ability to go out there and
be the guys that we were you know at
Miami because so many of those guys
walked through those doors you fast
forward a year from there my senior year
the last drive to win the game
the shocky scored a touchdown Michael
Irvin was caught in place I literally
ran a pass caught the ball my girl said
come out of bound god of mine sake take
a breather let somebody else go in I
need you to make another play put me
back in and I run another play make a
play
put us closely a shock you scored a
touchdown it's crazy but that's the kind
of guys that we had it came back and
they thrived in us in those moments and
made us who we were because we were
sitting in those seats watching them do
that thing for so many years you didn't
have a tree calling out coverages and
stuff to you man listen
it read was on everything back then and
then you know that that's the guy who I
always say you know he eats the awesome
that's the first definition of
leadership you know when I when they say
you know leadership or you know a lot of
people you know they days they say and
true you know you're such an awesome
leader I'm like I've had great examples
in front of me you know all we have to
do is follow the trend because we had
great examples in front of us and it was
set in stone you know like we I carry in
number six right I got the number six
after Santana so if I don't live up to
those expectations that number was what
that number was but I didn't even know
it number six before he put it on that
number was forever on the spotlight at
that point you know once he carried then
I carry we're always watching who wore
number six you know so you got to go out
in you got to play ball like you say
that's just our mentality being you know
from the South Florida Miami region we
know how to play ball we know how to go
out there and get it a dissin era where
everybody pretty much does they're three
years and they move on to the NFL with
the exception there are a few players
but you guys stayed it to you even after
junior seasons you guys were stars
already you probably could have went off
to the NFL is there any reason or is it
a private reason with the you why you
went back for that extra year well
personally me I remember having those
talks surprisingly I had close family
members that was in the NFL at the time
and it's like hey let me take you for a
ride after my junior season and this is
what you should be doing getting
yourself ready trying to show me hey
this is agent you need to talk to and I
won't look at me like he was trippin
like no man I'm straight he's like
you're going back you knew it all along
I knew it two reasons one I probably
mom's gonna get an education so well I'm
from the education might not seem like
it's something that kids go after but in
my household I don't think no one else
had one so [ __ ]
I work accomplish something real big
about go out then get my education a
college degree and yeah the money
sounded good you can hear all that stuff
but my mentality at the moment I wasn't
ready I was truly wasn't ready I didn't
know what what it was like with or
without the money so I
in the day I'm not hurting for it right
now you know I'm saying something like
picture how much money that is good I
can see it I can you know I can almost
imagine what it would be like what with
a life changing you know it would change
my life and our family lives but right
now my mom and dad busted their behinds
and I'm okay with that they okay with
that and I'm in school and they
definitely okay with me doing I'm doing
in school so I felt like when when that
time come I shall be ready and one more
year was it gonna hurt me yeah um for
myself you know we they we always send
in our draft grades you know we we we
request our draft grades and before my
junior season like that was never even a
thought for myself but like you say you
know shutting down larry fitzgerald like
you encounter johnson yeah and calvin
johnson away from here to literally
skyrocket yeah
and they told me you know we're
projecting him to go anywhere from late
first to early second for me you know
education was also that was always my
number one priority education education
i play a football because i loved it i
didn't play football
seeking to go to the NFL you know all
that thing all those things kind of
happen in stride so my number one thing
was education and after that once that
platform was presented to me as far as
late second round i mean late first
round
early second i was like nah that ain't
good enough for me like i I need I need
that top tier money you know that but
that was my mindset I want that top ten
money I know that if I give myself
another year I can reach this platform
and I just bet on myself I always bet on
myself you know no matter what the
situation is no matter how you know
impossible to Oz may seem I'm gonna bet
on myself
100 100 times and that was before the
rookie wave skills that top ten money
was a lot of different the first top ten
guys yeah a little different now how
connected are you guys to the you you
know I was like you're saying you know
you guys you were each other's number
and you you're always falling that guy
but through all the changes the last
couple years some some lean years for
the Hurricanes you guys still pretty
involved with everything going on down
I'm still involved to a certain extent
you know I'm in Washington more but when
I'm home you know I come home and visit
the family you know I've been a part of
the Paradise Camp they had that this
past summer and I tried to make sure I
remember at one point in time we didn't
work out nowhere but at um all the guys
whether you were still in the league or
not if you wouldn't work out who's gonna
be in that gym it's a lot of coaches
doesn't change now so you kind of kind
of you know you don't know if you're a
separate the same way but they've showed
us that hey these doors are wide open
especially when I just experienced this
experience that I had throughout the
Paradise Camp but I was just explaining
to someone backstage I'm looking forward
to the game tomorrow for that particular
reason because I have been away for so
long I haven't watched any practices
this offseason so I'm really looking
forward to see where our offense is that
I think I have them something in my mind
about the defense because what I saw the
past two seasons and they only could get
better you know just knowing that they
still have a bunch of those those guys
that the main nucleus is still there but
offensively I'm really intrigued about
what it's gonna look like and that's one
of the things I'm looking forward to the
most this year how about you um I don't
spend much time there as I would really
like to or like I said I had three kids
on three years old so that's what my
focus is that's what my priority has
been and you know it literally just
takes up all my time but I have watched
a few practices you know I've also
participated in the Paradise camp for a
couple of years and you know I'm like
Santana defense I think defense and go
out there and hold their own for the
most part you know they still have
whatever we like to call a couple dogs
on that defense that can set the tempo
offensively it's gonna be the huge
question mark for me you know the
offensive line we know that skill
position they're always gonna have some
guys that can once the balls in the hand
they can make things happen but our big
question is gonna be quarterback
offensive line you know can they managed
offense can they score when given
opportunities so it's gonna be it's
gonna be a huge test you know four-man
DVIDS and um hurricanes going up against
Florida on Saturday and everyone we
talked to I mean before the draft we had
Gerald Willis on from Miami and they
loved Manny Diaz are you guys you know
buying all the hype that's surrounding
him right
now I am I mean I'm pretty sure trailers
a defensive guy and those guys take a
look differently they they they they
wider look differently and I can say
being a guy that played both growing up
that's part of the reason why I played
offense the way I did because I was a
true corner safety at heart that's like
right now if you put me in a flag game
you know they have all these games now
for guys like ourselves and who retired
veterans and like hey you wanna come
playing this you know game the first
thing I said only if I'm playing defense
my plant corner I was I don't have
nothing in me in the tank left I'm
trying to be out there cutting and I'm
playing off and I'm playing defense
because I I can read the quarterback all
day that's what I grew up doing but the
way that many beers is wired the way he
has his defense wired that's one of the
reasons why I was so hyped about him
being the head coach because he wants
that offensively to he want that same
mentality that same motive he want what
motivated that difference you want that
on the off from the side and that's what
we've been lacking the last few years so
if he can have those guys going out
there cuz one of the things I remember
my playing years there you know we had a
coach or Curtis Johnson and he's a wide
receiver coach of the New Orleans Saints
right now and he used to tell me and
Reggie Wayne and Andre Johnson and you
name it the host of other probably you
know NFL wide receiver boy all of them
know he tell us in order for us to win
on the offensive side we got to do
something special as a receivers so men
I mentality in every game was like if we
don't do nothing specially we don't win
and when you go back and look at those
years it's always some special coming
out of that core of guys so that's what
you need you need a coach that's gonna
motivate those guys to be you know not
who they plan on being but something
beyond that something beyond they can
even imagine and that's what man in the
ASD on that defense that turnover chain
and all that stuff that they did they
they didn't expect to for it to be what
it is now but it's because he pushed
them to the limit and they went beyond
the limit that he pushed them to and
that's why it become so big and so I'm
hoping offensively we can have that same
kind of you know you know surge in us
coming this season how about you as the
defense of God you believe in Manny Diaz
and and everything he's brought to the
table so far 200% you know
many as a fiery guy there as we all we
can witness that you know just from the
Cylons you can witness as spectators but
I'm a firm believer in coaches coaches
players play the game yeah and as a
coach you can fire guys up you can you
can have them as prepared as you want
but that's only gonna last for so long
you know if it doesn't come within as a
player you're dead in the water so the
ultimate test is gonna be as the players
who's gonna lead and who's gonna be the
leaders that lead the others who's gonna
follow a train who's gonna set the
example who's gonna set the tempo and
keep the tempo riding we know you have a
couple of those guys on defense the
question mark is gonna be who are gonna
be those guys on offense and can they
honestly lead and I always said in my
time at University of Miami I get there
and there's a 6-5 lanky white boy
quarterback Ken Dorsey but I never saw a
general lead a group of black receivers
whatever Ken said you had a tree to
follow you had Andre Johnson to follow
you had Jeremy Shockey to follow he was
the complete general and I think right
now a University of Miami that's what
we've been missing for so long someone
who's not afraid to step out front and
lead doesn't matter your skin color
doesn't matter your physique it only
matters your mindset and what you
believe and if you know you're leading
and you can lead these guys then go out
there and do it and I think that's what
they've been lacking for you know quite
some time now
yeah and that makes me Santana it's
who's the best quarterback you think
you've ever played with I know you had
great times with Pennington he was hurt
a lot but a lot of success there
obviously back in Miami who do you think
the best one is that you play you want
me to pick all the quarterbacks all of
them highs from work start from college
to NFL you've played with a lot of
quarterbacks honestly man college I
would say hands down it's hard to say
just Ken Dorsey because I did some great
things with Kenny Kelly but what he just
spoke on ken Dorsey hit it dead on ken
Dorsey came in because Kenny Kelly got
hurt in the Virginia Tech game
I remember like it was you know
yesterday and I also remember that game
him throwing the ball so high that I got
my back blown out and Nate Webster
attacked him soon we come off the field
Nate Webster jacked him up and was like
you ever get Santana hit like that like
he like that's the type of guy here on
our team right
if you didn't do something right they
was gonna Jack you up and they was gonna
deal with it like our coaches and had to
coach us the players was gonna coach us
and so Nate Webster Jack Dorsey up and I
told Nate now leave him alone I got to
make that play cuz I wanted this guy to
believe look throw it again yeah next
time I have it indoors he looked at dad
and stuff and he was a young buck he's a
freshman and he said man I appreciate
that and that's how our relationship
started so the way we went from there
it's crazy as ironic as it may sounds
that how we grew to be who we were as a
combo when it comes to the place that I
was able to put up my the rest of that
year with him and my senior year and you
go over so hands down in college I'll
have to give him the nod but
professionally I spoke I speak a lot
about it now on my podcast on different
shows I do in Washington DC
the quarterbacks I love the most in the
pros was the who wants to older guys the
guys that experienced a lot and it was
Vinny Testaverde with the Jets even
though I love Chad Chad blue balls it
was soft as Charmin you know anyone
gonna catch that trust me I got to give
Chad credit but III did bigger things
with both of those guys but Vinnie was a
guy I appreciate a little more I think
because it was arm scrimped and when I
wasn't in the progression he still got
me the ball
that's something that I received like
myself you know that's the you know what
we want we want to be that guy that no
matter what players call even when I'm
backside you can get me a ball so Vinnie
did that for me in New York and when I
got to DC Mark Brunell the season that
we had my first year out racing it was
crazy how short it was cut because mark
was just didn't give him the opportunity
to to be the guy that I knew he could be
the next couple of years that I had with
him but Mark Brunell he was like Vinnie
it was like being in being with Vinnie
all over again I remember the first year
one of my fondest memories of Mark you
could say that 2005
season was very memorable from us their
money my miracle that we experienced in
in Dallas and just my stats along and
March stats but in oh six one of my
fondest memories one of my best games
and I think on my career
we played Jacksonville and we was
playing them at home and I'm a Florida
guy so you know you want to beat your
Florida teams right know we have one of
those things about us like when you play
a team from where you you grew up and
who you've been watching you want to
stick it to him and early in that game I
ran a play backside and Mark came to me
surprisingly and say hey hi how did you
look and what receivers going to tell
you that he wasn't open I was not a
single one and I was lying and I was
lying but hey you asked me so I was open
mark and surprisingly we get into the
game it's now we're gonna throw overtime
I already have two touchdowns and we
break the huddle it's the same play we
were in the first quarter and I'm just
standing myself damn I told mark I was
open last time I better make sure I be
opening this time because he might come
to me
look at my covers pre-snap read I got a
cloud on my side I saw at doubling me I
had deon grant playing safety a guy who
the corner backwards but I saw his
positioning how he had his back to the
sideline a little shade inside me
I like this cover too and so when I took
my two steps off the line he didn't
budge I saw her I'm gonna go around
because it's covered - I see grant
covering the top so the way I could run
around you know I'm always running the
same tempo I said let me still get to my
point just to make sure I got there I
was in loss loafing and I see the ball
in flight coming my way
so I peek at beyond grand I peek back at
the ball and I just made a play on it
took it to the house we win the game
mark fuhrman Brut Marvin L came back to
me when I told this guy that I was open
and that right there was something that
a lot of the other quarterbacks that I
had a chance to play with I never
experienced that these guys actually
these questions because they want to
have the best chance to happen you know
for us to win and I experienced that
with all the other guys I never got a
chance to experience it with the young
quarterbacks and I had a lot of those
in my career intro when we were talking
to Clinton and he was laying down the
case for running back you at Miami and
now everyone wants to talk about Ohio
State Texas might be DBU but I've just a
list of guys that played at Miami from
before you to the time that you were
there and a little bit after I would
love for you to make the case for Miami
to be DBU well not making the case
that's exactly what it is it's just that
simple right simple I mean when you're
talking about University of Miami in our
time they're sent ten times and you know
the times were you're our blades and you
know the Benny blaze and Brian blades it
we not only do we excel in the College
on the collegiate level we are cell on
the NFL level also yeah you know when
you're talking about a read Sean
Taylor's myself I mean that the list
goes on and on and on and there's a
couple of guys like in my opinion one of
the best corners I've ever witnessed and
I was a huge fan of also was full of
Buchanan you know to me is NFL career
didn't pan out as I would have thought
it would because he was honestly he was
dynamic yeah but he was special he'd do
everything everything he was he was a
special breed University of Miami and
obviously you know when he went to the
NFL you know he experienced some things
that probably could have you know swayed
in his career one way or another you
know I can't be the one to really speak
up on that but he was a guy looking to
see like you know this guy's gonna do
some amazing thing like a Charles
Woodson type player NFL at that type of
caliber but with more of an upside
because he was faster he was stronger he
would be was he was he was special yeah
he was he was a gifted breed but
universe in Miami I mean there's there's
corners and safeties come on Alabama LSU
you know that you give credit where
credit do I mean some of those guys are
absolutely phenomenal but I'm gonna
always say that University of Miami is
DBU just from what we producing cards
and also how we sustain that in NFL when
you took your visit there besides
Santana was there anyone that really
stood out to you where you were like I
need to go here like this is a part of
the family that I want to be a part of
it wasn't it wasn't a visit I did it for
me
it was it was going to their practice
you see now they work and I'll just head
out for one it was - it was two thoughts
that crossed my mind my first thought
was man I I don't know this is for me
because it seemed like they were moving
in fast forward and I'm like I'm like
okay like I can run them fast but these
guys look like they're moving at a
different pace I didn't know if I was
ready for that and another thing was
just the camaraderie the Brotherhood the
intensity of practice I've always been a
physical guy you know I promise elf on
being physical being tough and that's
exactly what they showed me their their
practice and then once the whistle blew
this guy giving this guy water they hug
and you know they have him funny jumping
around and I was like how the hell did
they switch that off and all I didn't
understand it I really didn't understand
it but I want to be a part of it yeah
you know I'm like these guys crackback
City going like get like literally
trying to kill each other and it was
just practice and once that whistle blew
it's like a you know it's like clap on
clap off yeah and if that Brotherhood
start to form and you start to see there
you start to see you know they're
talking about players and what happened
here boy you let me up here like and I
want to be a part of that so bad and
then the same week they play Florida
State and it's 200 degrees outside and
I'm in the stands and all I see is these
guys come out to smoke yeah and I see
this whack and I say man I want to be a
part of that so bad they didn't have to
win the game maybe have to win the game
it was it was that energy I was like Oh
Mike I gotta be a part of this so it was
set in stone they will set a stone love
that before we let you guys go we have
to ask for a prediction for the game
Saturday and I think I know you're both
gonna say but I just want to put it on
record I mean they got us to lose so I'm
just gonna say we gonna win this it's
easy and simple you know I mean I think
the last time we faced these guys there
was ranked and we upset them so let's do
it again you know me well you don't go
my boys all day yeah I knew you were all
day all day you know and I don't I don't
want them just to win I want them to
dominate yeah I want them to go out
there dominate you know set the temple
early
and hopefully they can they can keep
that going you know for the for the
games to come it's a little
disrespectful it's just gonna say at top
25 and a 7 point under disrespectful
earn it man they're enough I love my you
yeah I'm not gonna be biased gotta earn
it you gotta earn it and they have they
have Ernie yet no it's not disrespectful
you you you get what you deserve I would
hate for them to come into this season
with so much hype and they haven't
earned it
so roof don't give us nothing let's go
out there and earn it any Saturday and
you see us creep back into that thing
you mean you heard it from us appreciate
you guys thanks so much for coming out
we had a lot of appreciate you
definitely